foreign
in Pittsburgh what's up Caitlin
thank you hey what's up hey I pulled
into your show back in October yeah the
question then was along the lines of I
felt like I was placing trauma onto my
kids because of depression and
disassociation okay my question today is
I have lived all my life numbing my
emotions due to trauma
I don't know how to connect to myself or
emotions and emotions terrify me
I also feel paralyzed
paralyzed from Fear With Fear from
pretty much doing anything in life so
where do I start to connect to myself
animation without being paralyzed by
fear wow what happened
well as a child I was sexually abused by
my dad man I'm so sorry
how long did that go on Caitlyn
um
quite a few years yeah
who ultimately took care of you
um my parents I I don't know
who came and rescued you Kayla
nobody
when did you finally Escape that Madness
oh it's
it's
um
in my team so yeah it just all of a
sudden stopped
did your mom know
uh no
does she know now
yes
where's your dad now
um
is she in jail um
apparently it's currently in the process
oh man
I'm so sorry Caitlyn
um
I wish you'd had a better dad
little Caitlyn deserved that and teenage
Caitlyn deserved that and grown-up
Caitlyn deserve that
do you have kids of your own now
yes how old are your kids
um eight seven
or no nine eight six and two okay we may
have talked about this in the last
called it
have you found your own trauma responses
um escalating as you've added more kids
to the fold and they've gotten to
um the age you were when this madness
started
yes okay
are you going to talk to anybody
yes I'm expecting a therapist for
sport enough
and it's not doing any good
um
he says she
you know made a big change but from a
lot of the days I don't need myself
um
I can tell you
from my personal experience and from
sitting with a bajillion people
the end of the day
trauma disconnects somebody from
themself
well the way you described it that I
have trouble feeling I have trouble
connecting with my emotions is a perfect
way to to explain that and if somebody
hasn't been abused they haven't
experienced childhood trauma they
haven't experienced big trauma they
don't really understand what it feels
like to
literally be walking down the street and
feel disconnected from your own feet
or to feel like your body's on fire just
because you have a two-year-old crawling
all over you or
um you just want to scream and run out
of the house just because your kids are
laughing too loud
it's this disconnection from yourself so
the goal of any sort of
therapeutic intervention is
to reconnect with yourself
the hard part is
your body's put a pin in that as we
cannot do that again because the one
person who is supposed to keep us safe
our dad violated that
at its core
so after a year and a half
um
if you haven't already you have to enter
into some sort of and this is from the
great Peter Levine's work you have to
enter into some sort of body work
that can look as simple as you having a
guided therapist that you trust who just
simply
puts their hands on you like on your
shoulders and on your head and on your
chest and on your arms as you go back
and re-experience some of these things
and teach your body what good touch and
Safe Touch feels like
or let me say it another way you can't
talk and think your way through healing
on this
you might be a great candidate for some
of the newer procedures that are out
like the psychedelics and ketamine and
some of these other
therapies that are showing some great
clinical promise but you have to have
the right practitioner you can't just go
Crank that stuff out on your own it's
very very unsafe and unstable if you do
it by yourself
but it may be that what happened to you
and for the duration of how it happened
to you was so profound and now you're
surrounded by four kids and so you're
trying to change the oil on this car
while it's driving it may be that you
need to have some more radical
interventions with folks that know what
they're doing
some of my close close friends in the
military Community have just
just
told me wonderful incredible stories
extraordinary stuff
but you have to enter into a new phase
of okay I'm ready to reconnect
and just know that that's not fun and
it's scary
is that something you're interested in
Caitlyn
you're being the way I am right
so and the reason like the reason for
this call was my therapist is working on
emotions right now
and it seems like every single time I
try and do that
I go into this phase of suicidal
thoughts and everything yeah I I again I
your therapist has been working with you
for 18 months and so there's a lot more
than that your therapist can glean from
you than I can in a few minutes of a
phone call
um
I personally wouldn't be doing emotion
work right now
what you're describing is deeply seated
inside of you and your body
now if if he or she is trying to get you
to feel a certain thing in therapy where
it's safe in there to feel an emotion
and sit with it for a bit that might be
what's happening and you get flooded
with all kinds of wild thoughts
because your body's been working really
hard to not feel anything because last
time we feel something it was filled
with
um
pain and
innocence being stolen and all those
things
but at the end of the day I I think
having a direct conversation with your
therapist that I've been doing this for
18 months
and I'm ready ready to enter into a more
directive
focused healing
preferably around some sort of Bodywork
if we have to do emotion work great but
it's got to be done in a safe
therapeutic context which hopefully is
what your therapist is providing you
um
but it's at some point you can't keep
talking about the same stuff the healing
doesn't happen that way you have to
reconnect with your body that's the
disconnection that's the trauma
your body's going to remain overwhelmed
by all these memories and all these
feelings and all these emotions and all
these Sensations
until your body learns hey we weren't
safe then and we are safe now and please
know everybody listening I know what I
am saying sounds like woo-woo I get it
I get it
but I can tell you personally I have
tracked my sleep score and my HRV as
I've entered through
um
this type of therapeutic intervention
and my whole life is changing
everything is changing
for the better as my nervous system
finally begins to slow down so all I
have to say is Caitlyn we're with you
we're with you
it's time to have a direct conversation
with your therapist about okay 18 months
in cool
it's time to make some changes we need
to do some body work we need to do some
more directive trauma work maybe some
EMDR and if not maybe it's time to get a
new trauma therapist or
it's time to look at some of these more
experimental
um Solutions with guided practitioners
and researchers who know exactly what
they're doing
I'm grateful for you Caitlin I wish I
could provide you more instantaneous
like magic wand help here this is just
going to be a slog my promise is
there is healing on the other side if
you'll make the journey
please don't go alone